1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 verschiedene Pastasoßen aus dem
Supermarkt wir haben pestoerde Pesto
rosso Bolognese basilico und Carbonara
wir finden raus welche supermarktsße die
Beste ist und wie gut diese Soßen
wirklich sind los geht's da sitzen wir
also und was ich vor mir sehe macht mir
nicht nur Freude ihr kennt das Setup
eric ist da brümmi ist da wie letztens
bei den bundeslandgerichten testen wir
uns hier einmal quer durch die Bank
links anfangen rechts anfangen was sagt
ihr komm wir fangen einfach links an das
ist einmal das miraculi der Klassiker
viele von euch kennen wahrscheinlich
diese miraculi Box wir vergleichen ja
die Soßen deshalb ist miraculi auf diese
Art und Weise mit dabei und ich stell
das einfach mal vor mich wir nehmen uns
alle eine Gabel und wir sehen hier auf
jeden Fall die Konsistenz es ist alle es
sieht alles ein bisschen traurig aus es
riecht auch einfach nach Industrie und
ich glaube ich werde heute nicht meine
größten Geschmackserlebnisse haben aber
für euch machen wir das ganze um
herauszufinden welche Soße sich
vielleicht doch zu kaufen lohnt man
denkt es ist schlechter die italienische
Küche über zeugt immer durch ihre
Zutaten und Industrie und Zutaten
vertragen sich nicht du merkst die die
Tomaten die da drin sind relativ viel
Säure der basilikum ist kein guter
Basilikum schmeckt nicht fatal ich hatte
viel mehr Angst wir sind wieder mit der
tierlist unterwegs haben extra eine
tierlist angelegt Fotos gemacht von
allen 3 2
1 d zweimal e schnelles e miraculi tut
mir leid aber
AUA weiter geht mit Barilla basilico ich
früher oft gegessen lange nicht mehr ich
weiß nicht wie es euch geht das war so
ein Ding das war immer im Schrank ne
also Mama war arbeiten dann hast du dir
so ein Ding aufgemacht und ist dir
irgendwie reingepresst auch hier noch
mal Konsistenz ich find es eigentlich
nicht schlecht also es bindet ganz gut
an die Nudeln die Soße es riecht nach
diesem klassischen Barilla Basilikum mag
ich nicht so gern konzentrieren wir uns
wieder auf Barilla machen uns eine Gabel
fertig wer heute aus diesem Video mit
einem sauberen Pulli geht hat auf jeden
Fall
gewonnen Barilla
Geschmack barill prgt einem wirklich
diesen Barilla Geschmack krass in den
Kopf und ich glaube das ist dieser
Basilikum den die verwenden der so eine
ganz fast so wie Minze so eine
eigenartige frische hat ja Minze ist das
richtige Wort ich find es auch
übertrieben süß ist sehr sehr süß ich
glaub Barilla arbeitet viel mit Zucker d
e e schon wieder dürfen wir d machen ich
würde sagen wir machen d Ich find
miraculi krasser ja ja aber wir können
uns auf D einigen okay weil weil zwei
von drei Z von sind dafür deswegen ja
das ist wirklich die pure Tristess ja
das das stimmt ich habe genauso viel ihr
seht sogar da ist genauso viel Soße raus
wie bei allen anderen sollen wir
reingehen let's go riecht auch wirklich
schon einfach so noch saurer als die
Miracoli schmeckt Hal am natür also so
am wenigsten gepimmt schmeckt am
wenigsten gepimmt ja ich finde das
schmeckt aber so wie die Miracoli aber
so geschmacksregler ein bisschen weniger
aber auf eine angenehme Art und Weise
weil die anderen haben so so industriell
geschmeckt ich find also die ist
natürlich auch industriell gefertig ne
aber ich finde die schmeckt irgendwie
besser 3 2 1 Alter ich hätte es never
ever gedacht dass die so gut performen
okay ein haben wir noch probieren wir
bertolly Bertolli finde ich ist so
bisschen edler als Barilla aus barill
Barilla ist so für die Masse und
bertolly ist so ein bisschen so für die
die sich war mal was Gutes tun wollen ne
3 2 1 c c ne CBB das Ding ist ich habe
nur B gemacht weil ich nicht will dass
es auf einer Stufe mit ja ist aber es
ist auch nicht B ist keine B also jede
Tomatensoße die ich im Restaurant
gegessen habe schmeckt besser auch jede
die ich selber gemacht habe weißt du was
wir vielleicht machen sollten reinziehen
alles eins runter aber ist miraculi das
schlechteste ja ja ja die beste ist
Durchschnitt alle anderen sind
schlechter weiter geht's mit der
nächsten soßenkategorie es ist wieder
soweit wir haben Pesto rosso vor uns
stehen nicht zu zu vernachlässigen so
ein bisschen so der kleine Bruder von
pestoerde der immer ein bisschen
unterschätzt wird weil pestorosso wenn
es gut gemacht ist kann wirklich richtig
lecker sein gucken wir uns erstmal die
Konsistenzen an wichtig dabei zu sagen
ist bei allen haben wir drei Löffel
Pesto und zwei Kellen Nudeln also es ist
alles immer das genau das gleiche
Verhältnis bei allen
pasti kann man se una Pasta du Paste
Pesto Barilla Rosso sieht ohne Witz gar
nicht so wie stückiges Pesto sondern
viel mehr wie eine flüssige Soße aus
auch dass das wie so eine
tomatensahnesoße aus sieht aus wie so
sieh bisschen aus wie so eine Vodka
Sauce so so ein bisschen pestorosso von
ja sieht gar nicht so traurig aus wie
der basilico Bruder aber trotzdem
traurig hier haben wir deceeco
pestorosso Mascarpone definitiv auch
eine premium brand ne also würde ich so
einordnen pestorosso von oroitalia sind
glaube ich eher bekannt für für Tomaten
also du kannst da so passierte Tomaten
kaufen des deshal bin ich da sehr
gespannt drauf ob das vielleicht so ein
geheimer Favorit ist und zum Abschluss
der tolli hat ja echt gut abgeliefert
beim ersten Test schauen wir mal wie es
hier schmeckt wir starten wieder von
links nach rechts Barilla
pestorosso das ist schon lecker das ist
schon echt lecker ja da kann man jetzt
auch nicht so so die regelpizei spielen
schmeckt mir glaube ich auch direkt
schon besser als alle basiliko diger das
ist übelst cremig nicht so Barilla sty
viel zu viel süße und dieser
schreckliche Basil Barilla basilikum ist
auch nicht drin guck mal da haben wir f
d CB alles schon belegtes das hier wird
jetzt bestimmt unser s das ja pestosso
da sind penenkerne abgebildet da ist
Basilikum dabei sind auch Pinienkerne
drin 1,5%
immerhin das ist was ich mit fertig Soße
verbinde dieser Nachgeschmack 3
2 schlechter geht nicht finde absolut
keine Kaufempfehlung braucht man nicht D
wir getestet haben dass ihr es nicht
testen müsst das lohnt sich nicht darauf
bin ich sehr gespannt probieren wir
Rosse was ich geil finde alle drei PES
die schmecken ganz anders komplett
anders man kann jetzt nicht sagen dass
das so ein Einheitsbrei ist und das
irgendwie alles gleich schmeckt weil es
schmeckt überhaupt nicht gleich ein
Durchnitt kein diskutieren Triple C
jetzt sind wir bei orodital ja das will
was heißen ist ist eine tomatenmarke und
das ist ein tomatenpesto hat die Süße
der Tomate was ich das erste Mal richtig
schmecke ist eine Nuss boah das ist
schon das ist schon das ist schon echt
gut das ist nussig
3 2
1 b b okay ABB ABB bleiben wir beim B
der tolli zweifels ohne Champion gewesen
bei basiliko jetzt kommt auf pesterosso
an auch hier ne es ist wieder einfach
ziemlich gut bedeckt alles und
so jetzt kommt der Käse zuerst immer
noch nicht gekleckert aus auf dem
Tisch das war ja wirklich
geisteskrank oh junge Bri ah gott ist
groß merkt ihr das Pecorino Romano das
ist ein geschützter herkunftsbegriff
Pecorino ist ja sch ist ja
scharfsmilchkäse der direkt mehr Kraft
hat 3 2 1 c c B PST du raus so können
wir aber festhalten ist auf jeden Fall
eine gute Kategorie weiter geht's mit
einer Sache die wirklich nur schlecht
sein kann Spaghetti Carbonara natürlich
nicht ansatzweise so wie sie in Italien
gemacht werden es ist natürlich in
beiden Sachen Sahne drin und es ist auch
wirk eine Sache die mir ein bisschen
Angst bereitet das sind die einzigen
zwei Soßen Carbonara die wir gefunden
haben weil es einfach keine gute
Carbonara Soße auf dem Markt gibt das
ist einmal Knor Carbonara speale algusto
wen Gusto das ist und ob er gut ist
werden wir gleich herausfinden und hier
drüben ist wirklich eine tütencarbonara
cremig mit Speck und Käse frisch dazu
Spaghetti Schinkenwürfel Schlagsahne
haben wir genauso zubereitet wollten wir
eigentlich nicht mit reinnehmen aber wir
müssen ja irgendwie es vergleichen diese
Speckwürfel da drin machen wir so Angst
ist eine schöne Cremigkeit ne wie die
sich um die Nudel legt und so das ist
schon gut bedeckt alles bleib gut hasten
ja es riecht es riecht ganz
komisch ich wusste nicht wie schlimm
sowas ist also im Restaurant würde ich
den Kellner jetzt rufen W ich sagen ich
habe eine Carbonara bestellt so böse
gucken Bewertung oder müssen wir
überhaupt scheiß Handy rausholen nein
müssen
sch wirklich es ist wirklich einfach
fatal sieht so ein bisschen aus als wä
das Ei gestockt obwohl halt gar kein Ei
drin was halt auch krass war so was halt
auch wird war war so Speck anbraten und
dann 250 ml Wasser auf den Speck
kippen wir machen das für euch
Leute schmeckt viel besser es eine
andere Welt sogar 3 2 1 e D es ist
einfach traurig insgesamt ist ein E
kauft keine fertige Carbonara aus dem
Supermarkt ihr könnt euer Geld besser
investieren zwei Soßen haben wir noch
und jetzt kommen die absoluten
hochkaretter wir machen Spaghetti
Bolognese und danach Pesto werde
Bolognesesoße drei verschiedene
Varianten haben wir vor uns es gibt gar
nicht so viel Bolognese zumindest bei
uns im Supermarkt wie man denkt aber es
ist eine Sache die ein bisschen kritisch
ist weil ich glaube es könnte gut
funktionieren so von dem dass es
komplett gekocht ist eingepackt wird
dann wchst du das schön ein ne und dann
könnte das lange haltbar sein auch mit
einer guten Qualität was jetzt die
Hersteller hier abliefern bleibt
spannend wir starten mal mit der
Eigenmarke vom Supermarkt das ist jetzt
beste Wahl von Rewe wir hatten ja sonst
immer ja macht eigentlich vieles richtig
ne dann haben wir hier Barilla Barilla
ist im Vergleich ein bisschen nackt und
hier hinten haben wir einen ganz anderen
Farbton als bei den anderen das ist von
Magi das ist so ein tiefrot Magi hatten
wir gerade schon der Carbonara Tüte
dabei jetzt aus dem Glas ich bin
gespannt das sieht von den dreien für
mich jetzt gerade am wenigsten
appetitlich aus am tomatigsten aus finde
ich probieren wir erstmal beste Leben
Rewe besteewahl
Eigenmarke sauer erstmal so süß sauer W
hast du so eine kräuterkeule es ist eine
Tomatensoße mit Fleisch schmeckt nicht
nicht berauschend gut also ich würde nie
niemals diesen Teller noch leer essen ja
3 2 1 man will das nicht weil du hast
gerade gesagt ist alles besser als
basilico ich finde nicht mal das nicht
mal ein a haben wir geschweige den ein S
also es war klar dass es schwer werden
würde aber vielleicht passiert da noch
mal was an der pestofront weil das hier
sieht auch nicht besonders beeindruckend
aus wobei der Glanz an der Barilla Nudel
ist schon echt nicht verkehrt ne es
riecht ein bisschen nach babyglas finde
ich es schmeckt nach nichts es schmeckt
total flach man schmeckt weder Fleisch
noch irgendwie so frito wenn du eine
richtige Bolognese ist ich habe ja in
Bologna die beste Bolognese gegessen
dann ist das eine Fleischsoße mit Tomate
das ist halt ein ragua Bolognese und
hier ist das komplett umgedreht und
dadurch schmeckt aberfach nicht nach
Bolognese 3 2 1 e
e vernichtendes Urteil ja also ich würde
die auch noch runter raten auf ein F das
Ding ist das wirkt jetzt wirklich mega
mega mega beschissen aber wenn ich
richtig Hunger habe würde ich
wahrscheinlich jede Soße die wir heute
hatten essen da würde ich mich auch
freuen ja aber es geht ja gerade
wirklich darum das Ganze zu vergleichen
also bitte versteht das nicht falsch
alles hier steht so ein bisschen diese
wässrige Tomatensoße drin aber was mir
jetzt auf den ersten Blick ganz gut
gefällt ist dass wir eine schöne große
Karotte hier haben ordentliche
Stücke nach basilik ja ja schmeckt
literally nach
basilikoatensoße
für wir suchen die ganze Zeit das
Fleisch Zubereitung mit Fleisch oder
Fleisch alternative Hackfleisch anbraten
Soße zugeben und heiß werden lassen okay
wir wir bewerten die Basis stellen uns
vielleicht vor dass da was noch dass da
gut Hackfleisch drin ist gehen deshalb
einen hoch würde ich dann sagen oder ja
seid ihr ready 2 1 d d e e ja dann gehen
wir in D rein D war relativ einsam
bisher ja aber es ist wirklich noch viel
Luft nach oben fünf verschiedene
pestoerde haben wir noch die testen wir
jetzt und dann mache ich wirklich so
einen gigantischen Bogen um das
soßenregal im Supermarkt weil Mama m das
ist kein leichtes Video heute Pesto
genes das ist ein ganz ganz wesentlicher
Punkt Pesto Genovese haben wir ja nicht
wir haben zweimal Pesto all Genovese ne
dreimal Pesto all Genovese und zweimal
pestoerde gucken wir von links nach
rechts bertli trumpft mit einer grauen
Optik es sieht irgendwie traurig aus
varilla ist glaube ich Bestseller
Klassiker ist schon wieder so ein
bisschen hier so neben den Regeln die
haben wieder sowas cremiges sahniges
irgendwie schon fast ein bisschen dann
sind wir hier bei Discounter bei ja
Eigenmarke hier steht auf jeden Fall
schön das Öl wer mal selbst Pesto
gemacht hat weiß dass Pesto im
Wesentlichen Öl ist de ceco sieht auch
traurig aus die Teile die so abgeholt
haben sehen auch traurig aus si aus wie
Spinat also ohne Witz jeder der mich
kennt weiß dass Supermarkt Pesto mich
traurig macht weil ich bin einfach ich
bin verwöhnt ich bin aufgewachsen mit
einer Mama die frisches Pesto gemacht
hat ich habe jetzt bei mir im
Kühlschrank noch Kuss geht raus an Mama
habe ich frisches selbstgemachtes Pesto
stehen von meiner Mama das das bringt
die mir dann mal vorbei und so und dann
weiß ich dass ich hier an all diesen
Sachen einen großen Umweg vorbeim machen
kann wir judgen aber wie gesagt niemand
der auch wenn es die ganze Zeit so
klingt komm starten wir mit berolly hat
schon mal gut ab abgeliefert irgendwie
ist das hängen geblieben bei mir riecht
säuerlich bevor irgendjemand mich
beleidigt ne weil ich pfertiges Pesto
schlecht mache macht bitte einmal selbst
Pesto weil ihr könnt in 15 Minuten ein
geiles Pesto selbst machen guck tiktok
vorbei bewerten müssen wir das ganze
bertli 3
Z machen e fertig m F hatten wir
wirklich schon Sachen die wirklich ein
Ekel auch bei mir ausgelöst haben F für
fies auch und e finde ich ist einfach
nur schlecht aber schmeckt halt nicht
gut ill pese
übel süß das ist besser geworden die
Spielen wieder nicht mit den Regeln mit
ja ne die machen wirklich ihr eigenes
Ding dier ist einfach süß ja okay 3 2 1
d C Stimme C zu gerade in dem Vergleich
hier in dem ganzen das ist besser als
dieses Maggi Bolognese hät nicht gedacht
ja next auch sehr bekannter
Geschmack ich würde fast sagen das
schmeckt so wie das
ogillaier mm schmeckt wie
dasilla genauso deswegen Scheiße 3 2 1
FFF F weil F ist für mich nur noch was
eklig ist das ist nicht eklig eklig ich
würde nicht essen aberceco Pesto all gen
Wese hat viel mehr Geschmack als das
davor woll ich sagen diese Säure ja aber
was mir fehlt ist auch so dieser
Knoblauch ein bisschen das vieles nicht
vorhanden ja nirgendwo sind penkne das
ist halt alles
Cashew whatever und vielleicht so ein
kleines fizzchen pinenkerne deshalb hat
natürlich gar nichts geschmacklich damit
zu tun aber es war schon Ecke besser 3 2
EDC machen die goldene Mitte ich fin
locker auf dem Level von
Barilla P die letzte pastasße am
heutigen Tage und somit auch die letzte
Hoffnung weil das Pesto rosso hat das
meist richtig gemacht ja wir haben jetzt
ein pestowerde von
oroitalia was so viel heißt wie das Gold
Italiens die Hoffnung ist groß aber die
Erwartungen sind
niedrig was ist das für eine Säurenote
das Basilikum ist halt schlecht Gefühl
also wir haben auf jeden Fall einige
tomatenfarms aber ihr habt keine
Basilikum farms weil das ist echt nicht
lecker 3 2 1 f F völlig verdient wie ich
finde
das war wirklich eine wilde ein wilder
Ritt also S und a sind komplett frei
geblieben es waren aber Überraschung
dabei ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
Barilla so häufig abliefert ich dachte
irgendwie die wären so ein bisschen zu
Unrecht so als beste Fertigsoße gehalibt
aber selbst die beste Fertigsoße ist
kein Vergleich zu einer richtig guten
Pastasoße also müssen wir euch nicht
erzählen hätten wir hättet ihr
wahrscheinlich auch vorher gewusst es
war heute einfach keine Soße dabei die
ansatzweise so g ist wie selbst gekocht
deshalb stellt euch in die Küche macht
euch ein leckeres Pesto und genießt es
wenn es mal schnell gehen muss dann
werde ich euch nicht verurteilen wenn
ihr euch auch mal sowas reinönnt danke
fürs zusehen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Video wieder macht's gut ciao ciao